[Music]
[Music]
i'm here to kill chaos
that's my mission
looks like chaos has been waiting for us
[Music]
you're gonna make us go in there and
find you
i guess we'll just show ourselves in
i only know one thing i want to kill
chaos we need to die
it's not a hope or a dream it's like a
hunger
thirst move aside
you're just
[Music]
you sure chaos is here yeah i can only
squash monsters for so long
i hate doing pest control this is the
shrine of chaos
he's here we just have to hunt him down
[Music]
the darkness is so thick i can taste it
this is it
no doubt die already
there was a knight who left on the same
journey as you
but never returned his name was garland
you could i would be grateful if you
looked for him
[Music]
chaos
i'll crush you know when you're beaten
and who are you we're here
to kill chaos the prophecy's very own
warriors of light
[Music]
he always wore such splendid armor
with a helmet that was terrifying to
behold
it's garland no
i become chaos
you